in a story that makes absolutely no
sense Texas senator Ted Cruz has just
become the chairman of the Subcommittee
on space science and competitiveness as
republicans have taken over the house
yeah i had to actually read that because
it doesn't seem possible why does this
seem like an odd choice for someone like
Ted Cruz to be heading up a
science-based committee well let's
listen to his thoughts on global warming
and the problem with climate changes
there's never been a day in the history
of the world in which the climate is not
changing it so you don't believe that
there is any man-made reason for global
global warming or climate change what I
think is is the data are not supporting
what the advocates are arguing the last
15 years there has been no recorded
warming contrary to all the theories
that that they are expounding there
should have been warming over the last
15 years it hasn't happened okay so i'm
pretty sure that that last sentence that
he said is actually not true coward can
you do a little cleaning up on that
about the not warming yeah it's
completely it's just that make you [ __ ]
I'm just making it right it gets warm in
the summer hey yeah Ted Cruz like many
people who are you know have a political
agenda night he's not just naive about
this like he has a political agenda to
say that he doesn't believe in global
climate change because he you know gets
lobbying money from oily yeah we'll get
we'll get to the political crap yeah but
a this is a common argument is that they
can't figure out the difference between
climate and weather and these are two
different things climate is like general
patterns weather is what happens
day-to-day yeah it warm in the summer
and cold in the winter that's not gonna
change it seems to me that the other one
that they always say the people that
don't believe in global warming or
climate change or whatever we're calling
it now they always say well I'm not a
science Oh which to me is the worst
thing that they could possibly say
because that's the purpose of having
scientists yeah scientists prove things
and look for empirical evidence and then
we're supposed to acknowledge the idea
of a technocracy as opposed to democracy
we're like you put people that are the
most adept at solving these sorts of
grand challenges
positions where they actually can as
opposed to just like you know
Republicans have the sentence of Ted
Cruz is now in charge of this like
really important initiative right after
thing is that the voters voted him to
this like that's what bothers me you
know this was still a democratic trace
but you're so right i did i did a piece
way back when I worked at HuffPost about
Marco Rubio because he said I'm not a
scientist when he was asked how old the
earth is yeah he was like I don't know
6,000 years old I never he's like are
you serious i'm not i'm not a scientist
and it really pissed me off right and i
went on this tirade because I mean this
is what I have to say to you Ted Cruz
like are you an economist right aren't
you a four-star general because you have
a lot of strong opinions about war and
about finances and but you're not a
scientist so you can't think it's just
such a [ __ ] coppa right and that's
the thing you don't have to believe in
science is happening whether you believe
in it or not it's not a something they
give to take a leap of faith to accept
all right so let's just talk about the
political part of this for a second
because that's the part that I think is
particularly interesting so Ted Cruz
okay fine he doesn't believe in climate
change or whatever it is so be it why do
you think the Republicans would have
pointed to this now I get it he's a
powerful guy right now the Tea Party's
behind him but like to me this doesn't
seem like a winning type of thing so
what they're they're in charge of NASA
yeah but I mean that's that's the key to
this they're in charge of our space
exploration and they're putting a guy in
charge of the committee who doesn't
believe in facts because because he's
going to have a lot to do with budget
allocation and they don't want to be
putting money towards climate change the
Republican agenda is that they think
money should be going elsewhere that's
where all of this comes down to they
don't want to take federal money and put
it towards climate change research which
is a huge initiative at NASA so he is
probably going to start systematically
stripping NASA's budget of any sort of
initiatives that allow them to actually
monitor global co2 levels which is so
[ __ ] scary so I guess that goes to
your point of having some sort of what
do you call it a tech technocracy a
technocracy because we're politicizing
science which is completely insane yeah
it is i mean what if like you know they
put him in charge of like the brain
initiative or something you know that
votes on stem cell research and the
ethics you know like i think it's it's
terrifying and that has happened i mean
bush put a huge [ __ ] blog on stem cell
research and yeah let's not forget
either that James Inhofe is heading up
the committee that oversees the EPA and
if you don't know who James Inhofe is
this is a guy who not just denies
anthropogenic climate change but has
actually said the words something like
global warming is the greatest hoax
perpetrated against the American people
he thinks it's legitimately a hoax what
are they what are they trying to gain so
person I'd like a PA okay so if I'm just
if I was trying to go along their lines
of thinking for a second what they think
is that the green movement as a whole is
funded by people that are just pulling
hook so that they can make money very
similar to what the oil people are doing
right like is that you don't think they
believe that like I think they're
they're trying they like the idea that
somehow al gore and the rest of them are
pushing these green technologies on us
because they own the companies that are
investing in I think they've convinced
themselves of that because it's the only
way to justify continuing to take money
from these oil industry is I think it's
kind of the same way that if you were in
bed with big tobacco you would try and
keep figuring out a way to make sure
that you could justify that big tobacco
is making profit yeah and you might do
it by minimizing something else because
I I mean I can't imagine that somebody
actually believes that green technology
is taking like money out of the mouths
of America is like just insane burning
industry to it'll create so many jobs
like well that's the and that's what I
mean about the economic part of it it's
like you know what if we invest in green
energies and then the oil industry is
hurt by that well we'll just shift jobs
elsewhere that's what that's what an
economy is supposed to do that's what
progress does you mean the coal industry
is it the same as it was 50 years ago
don't you think Ted Cruz is literally
thinking oh NASA's been allocating a lot
of money towards towards measuring co2
that's not a real issue you know I'm a
religious guy and I don't think that
only God can affect the climate and the
rapture is coming soon so we don't need
to worry about it instead I think NASA
should be um they should be working on
these satellites that we can put in
place for defense what I really think
that that's problem yeah
pretty much agree with you and I think
he's mostly doing things for political
purposes I don't even know what he acts
because I do think he's a smart human
he's a smart person so I don't know what
his real beliefs are anything either yes
he's a politician and he's the kind of
the worst of the worst kind of
politician yeah so final thought on this
why do people fear science whenever we
do these stories on science I am
consistently amazed at the amount of
people we could parade up to just talk
about how science isn't real that things
that are proven aren't real meanwhile
they have iphones in their pocket right
they use they watch television I mean
everything else everything in life is
based in science I don't know I mean you
can probably be better to this you
probably get your share of you know both
sides of the fence people that are
obsessed with science people they're
haters I think people are afraid of what
they don't understand I really think
that that's fear breeds kind of anger
fear breeds like it's the same reason
that people are racist it's the same
reason that people are homophobic it's
because they don't understand that
culture they don't understand that
lifestyle and they haven't been exposed
to it and I don't think that science
literacy is where it needs to be in our
country I don't think that we are doing
an amazing job of helping kids get into
science early and and continue to
understand science and because of that
we have scientifically illiterate adults
who are afraid of what they don't
understand
you